bueno yo les vengo a platicar el por qué
es el maestro es extraordinario cuando
yo era chiquita jugaba a ser maestra
ponía mis muñecos en una fila o estaban
muy callados con un lápiz y una en donde
anotar pero todos tenían que estar en
mucho silencio y claramente había un
curro platicando con maestros con
alumnos y con amigos me di cuenta que
mucho jugamos a ser maestros
generalmente los hombres no que eso
también es importante para otro tema
pero me di cuenta que era muy similar en
esta parte de mucho control y de que
estuvieran en silencio regañado si había
quien tenía hojitas de colores para
ponerles hasta reporte de minicis pita
dentro de mí y decía que yo quería ser
maestra pero por alguna razón decidí
ignorarla
y pasó el tiempo crecí y también deja de
lado esta idea de ser maestra si es que
estudie derecho y en una oportunidad un
amigo que es maestro de inglés me pidió
que lo supiera yo no tenía trabajo en
ese momento entonces decidí suplirlo y
ahí me di cuenta que me había equivocado
que lo mío lo mío es trabajar con niños
y adolescentes entonces dejé la carrera
de derecho a un semestre de terminarla y
decidí estudiar psicología estudié
talleres diplomados cursos para
finalmente convertirme en docente
docente es por definición aquella
persona que dedicada de manera
profesional que ayuda a los niños o al
alumno a llegar a la comprensión plena
cuando yo empecé a dar clases ya como
maestra titular tenía muy en mente el no
ser como algunos maestros que a mí me
tocaron cuando hebe cuando estaba en
kínder tenía una maestra que daba
seguidos al final del trabajo y yo
siempre quería tener los éxitos que
tenían mis amigas o mis hermanas un búho
el símbolo de inteligencia o sabiduría o
la abejita trabajadora pero no me lo
tiene me gane la tortuga por lenta y me
gane un marranito por trabajo sucio
supongo que no hacía bien las ruedas o
algo hacía mal y también supongo que
ella tenía toda la intención de
motivarme pero no lo hizo y esos delitos
no se quedaron solamente en este
cuaderno marcaron muchas experiencias en
mi vida y me persiguieron hasta el día
de hoy que lo estoy contando verdad
entonces cuando empiezo a dar clases
tengo muy claro que no quiero ser como
esa maestro que si quiero ser diferente
tengo que escuchar a mis alumnos
entonces en una ocasión lleva a mis
alumnos de segundo de primaria al
zoológico vamos entrando al zoológico y
un niño me dice
me inspiró me hallo sin palmas
no sabía que era un impala para que no
lo sepa es un antílope un tipo de
antílope y entonces eligió quejas y
ahorita los vemos mis quiero verlos
impalas mis quiero verlos impalas mis
quiero verlos sin balas ahí vamos a
hablar los impala saqué el mapa y me
fijo en donde están los impalas están en
esta dirección pero justo antes están
los racks que son unos búfalos para los
que tampoco se estamos parados viendo a
los yaks se acerca marco y me dice mis
esto es una
más o menos dice lo mismo entonces abrí
los ojos respire y le dije no entiendo
que me quieres decir y me dice me abre
los ojos como muchos alumnos o hijos
a mí una cuando los animales
caminan juntos a una manada
eso es lo mismo lo mismo y así como las
palabras son importantes también es
importante saber escuchar escuchar no
sólo a nuestros alumnos sino escucharnos
a nosotros mismos
saber escuchar involucra vincularse con
sus alumnos significa abrir un canal de
comunicación para que ellos escuchen lo
que les queremos decir pero nosotros
también tenemos que escuchar lo que
ellos quieren lo que lo que los quiere
decir no solamente hablando se trata de
interpretar también silencios gestos a
veces cambios de movimiento cambios de
actitud pero este este escucha no
solamente desde un lado desde los dos
lados los maestros también necesitamos
ante unos vistos y escuchados en son de
la chispita que les hablaba hace rato
hace que nuestra chispita se prenda
todavía más
nosotros como docentes tratamos de que
la chispa de los de nuestros alumnos o
la descubran o se hagan más grande pero
sobre todo que nunca se apague
sin embargo bueno pasa el tiempo y con
el tiempo me he dado cuenta que soy
docente y soy maestra y en algún lugar
escuché que ser maestro le da una
dimensión humana
y generalmente pensaríamos que los
maestros son mayores tiene que ver con
lo que decían hace ratito de que tal vez
los adultos nos creemos sino superiores
pero que tenemos más verdad y yo
descubierto que no mis alumnos me han
enseñado infinidad de cosas me han
enseñado que son los impalas ya sea
sobre tecnología sé sobre música sé
ahora que los juegos online no se les
puede poner pausa no lo sabía ahora
tengo una adicción a un juego gracias a
mis alumnos y también he descubierto que
no solo ellos que es más allá del salón
de clases que nos nos enseñan una señora
en el súper me enseñó a escoger fruta
que no sabía me han enseñado a usar el
cajero automático desde el celular me
han enseñado infinidad de cosas entonces
docente es quien lo hace de manera
profesional pero maestros somos todos y
en todos nosotros está cuidar la chispa
del que está lado porque nuestras
acciones y nuestras palabras impactan y
puede no generar una chispa o expander a
esa chispa o cuidar que no se apague la
pregunta creo que es que le quieren
enseñar al mundo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]